please welcome john canal
thank you for having me
okay
i
love your story
you became a teacher
you were a good teacher thank you but
something inside of you
felt another path that you would foster
by cooking in your off hours and feeding
your passion but what made it take over
into pole position
i mean there's two things happening here
my mom is from mexico and she instilled
a love of education me as part of why i
became a teacher
but she also had a love of cooking and
exploring flavors and just trying things
out and being adventurous and i got to
grow up with her in the kitchen
so even though i was a math and science
teacher and i loved it i still had a
passion for cooking that i nurtured and
it really kept me going
when my husband brian and i decided we
want to have a family and you guys live
on a farm we live on a farm now and like
we're both from l.a
now we live on this farm in connecticut
and
so we wanted to have kids and i knew i
wanted to be home more with them so i
took my love of teaching and my love of
food and i created preppy kitchen where
i get to be home with the kids but i can
also teach people how to make delicious
food and have fun in the kitchen i
really have to
um and your husband brian is in the
audience yes she is um
what's it like to live with someone who
can really cook
well i'm incredibly well fed as you may
imagine uh i like to consider myself the
chief tasting officer preppy kitchen so
it's fun i love that you call yourself
the chief tasting officer i can't cook
anything so i would starve to death
without john um okay so your upcoming
book that i've been searching high and
low for is coming out in october and it
is my pick for cookbook club what can we
expect
well
we're all from l.a right yes and when we
moved to connecticut i was like
i love this this is amazing like the
summer was this magical with like the
plants breathing and you guys feel it
you appreciate it yeah so
the seasons just affect every part of
your life and that's a big part of your
cookbook and we arranged all the recipes
by the seasons because i have different
needs in the winter i want to have cozy
just hearty delicious food like this and
different stuff available
[Music]